[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اغتالت اسرائيل ثلاثه
فلسطينيين في جنين شمال الضفه الغربيه
احدهم عضو في الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس
والاخر مقاتل في الجهاد الاسلامي نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر ل ناقشه في محورين ما مقاصد
اسرائيل من التصعيد رغم انسداد الافق
السياسي وما خيارات الطرفين في ظل التصعيد
الاسرائيلي وحاله التشرد
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيه لا يتوقف التصعيد الاسرائيلي
ضد الفلسطينين في الضفه الغربيه وغزه بل
على العكس يتخذ منذ اسابيع منحا تصاعديا
لاف ف وعلى كافه الصعد يقول المراقبون ان
تلبيب لم تعد تطيق حتى فكره الجلوس مع
المفاوض الفلسطيني ما الذي سيدفعها الى ان
تقدم تنازلات
لمفاوضات القضيه بين غزه والضفه بل ان
الوهن لحق اخيرا ببيته الحزبي اذ غدت
قياداته تتراشق فيما بينها تهم الخيانه
والعماله هذا المشهد لمواطنين فلسطينيين
غاضبين يشيعون شهدائهم الذين قتلهم جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تكرر بوتيره متزايده
منذ انطلاق المفاوضات الراهنه برعايه
ووسطه امريكيه بين الطرفين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي حيث تستفرد اسرائيل
بالمواطنين الفلسطينيين بينما نخبهم
السياسيه تزداد انقساما وضغ ارفض ارفض
هطار مع هذا هذا المشهد تتعالى في كل مره
اصوات الغضب المطالبه بوقف مفاوضات الاشهر
التسعه التي تعمل واشنطن على اطالتها عاما
اخر من وجهه نظر فلسطينيه شعبيه ورسميه
قطعت اسرائيل بهذا التصعيد الشك باليقين
بشان نواياها حيث اتخذت هذه المفاوضات
العاقر ستارا لمزيد من القتل والاستيطان
والقمع والعقوبات الجماعيه ضد الفلسطينيين
في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه وايضا القدس
المحتله ذرائع تلبيب تبدا بان الضحيه كان
مسلحا ويشكل قنبله موقوته ولا تنتهي بان
القاتل اصابه مس من جنون فكان بين الضحايا
القاضي والام والطفل والشيخ الى جانب
الشاب روايه لم تعد تحتملها اذان السامعين
هكذا في جنين التي ودعت ثلاثه من ابناء
مخيمها هم اخر الشهداء ال 60 الذين سقطوا
منذ انطلاق الجوله الراهنه من تلك
المفاوضات في تموز الماضي وهكذا في
الاستيطان المستشري بقرار حكومي اسرائيلي
رسمي عزز الاستيطان بنحو 11 الف وحده
جديده قابلها هدم اكثر من 220 منزلا
فلسطينيا وتصاعد في ارهاب المستوطنين
بنسبه تزيد على
40% ومعها تضاعفت اقتحامات اسرائيليين
يتقدمهم وزراء للمسجد الاقصى نهيك عما
تكابده غزه من قصف وحصار مزمن وبينما
تتغنى واشنطن بالطله البهيه لما تسميها
عمليه السلام ازداد الانقسام الفلسطيني
انقساما وتمادى الفرقاء في تقاذف اتهامات
يندها الجبين بينما سئم المواطن الفلسطيني
الاحتلال ومعه الانق سامات المتتاليه حتى
اضحى على يقين بانه في واد وان نخبه
القياديه على مختلف ولاءاتها في واد اخر
جبهه فلسطينيه متهالكه في وجه اله حرب
اسرائيليه لا ترحم تدفع الى مواجهه داميه
لفرض استسلام تسعى له اسرائيل وتسميه
واشنطن سلاما وليد العمري الجزيره الاراضي
الفلسطينيه موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه من رام
الله مع هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات
لابحاث السياسات ومن القدس مائير كوهن
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي ابدا معك سيد
مائير لماذا هذا التصعيد رغم الهدوء الذي
تشهده الضفه تجاه
اسرائيل نعم التصعيد لم يكن من جانب
اسرائيل وانما من جانب الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وهذا بدا في خطاء غزه باطلاق الجهاد
الاسلامي نحو 60 صاروخا في خلال يوم واحد
ثم بعد ذلك انتقل الى الوضع في الضفه
الغربيه نحن نرى ان حماس بتعيش اسوا
ايامها هي بتحاول بناء قوتها ا وقواعدها
الارهابيه في الضفه الغربيه بعد ان تلقت
ضربه في الثمانينات وبالتالي اسرائيل لم
تجد امامها من مناص سوى انها تتابع هذا
الشخص وهذا الشخص اعترف من خلال صفحته على
الفيسبوك بانه يتهيا للقيام بعمليه
ارهابيه حماس ايضا اعترفت بذلك واسرائيل
كانت تراقبه وبالتالي هي ارسلت قوه وهذه
القوه تعاملت معه وارادت القبض عليه واذا
به يطلق النار عليها وكانت هناك معركه
وبالتالي اسرائيل ما قامت به القوه هو كان
يتم من مبدا حق الدفاع عن النفس
اريد ان اسالك هاني المصري وانت تسمع هذا
الكلام هل يعني تقبل هذا التفسير ما الذي
يزعجك في التفسير الاسرائيلي
لهذه الحادثه
تحديدا ما يزعجني في هذا التفسير هو
المجرم الذي تقطر يداه يعني في الدماء
وينسى انه قوه محتله تقوم بمصادره الاراضي
وتهويدها واسرتها وتقوم بالاعتداء
سواء من قبل جيش الاحتلال او من قطعان
المستوطنين وخاصه في المسجد الاقصى ت تقوم
بعمليات قتل بارد هو تحدث عن عمليه قتل
مناضلين ولكنه تناسى ان في الاسابيع
والاشهر الاخيره قامت اسرائيل بقتل الكثير
من العزل والمدنيين بما ف القاضي
الاردني سيد هاني المصري حتى نعود لموضوع
الحلقه الان نتحدث عن هدوء في الضفه يعني
لو كانت نتحدث عن غزه اسرائيل تتذرع يعني
بكل بساطه بموضوع الصواريخ الان نحن نتحدث
عن الض الضفه تحديدا العمليه هذه التي
وقعت في الضفه كيف تفسر اقدام اسرائيل
عليها في هذه
المرحله الحرجه والهادئه من جانب
الضفه قبل ان انتقل الى الضفه قطاع غزه
يتعرض لحصار خانق تقوم به بشكل اساسي
اسرايل
وبعد ذلك وتقوم باعتداءات وتوغلت عندما
يكون هناك اي رد فلسطيني تقول اسرائيل
انها تمارس عمليه الدفاع عن النفس تنسى
الواقع الاساسي الذي هو الحصار الخانق
والاعتداءات شبه المستمره اما بال بالنسبه
للضفه الغربيه فاسرائيل تريد بالفتره
الاخيره ان تعمق نظريه الردع الاسرائيلي
وخاصه ان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي مشاي
علون هو صاحب ب نظريه كي الوعي الفلسطيني
وكي الوعي يكون من خلال توجيه ضربات
متواصله حتى يدخل الى اعماق الوعي
الفلسطيني استحاله مقاومه الاحتلال
استحاله رفض ما ريده اسرائيل وبالتالي في
الموضوع الاكبر اريد ان اعود لموضوعنا هنا
يعني ما حصل عمليه جن اريد ان اعود
لموضوعنا مائير
كن ربما السؤال الذي يساله كثيرون بما ان
التنسيق امني يفترض انه ممارس بين السلطه
والسلطات الاسرائيليه لماذا لم يتم اللجوء
اليه في هذه الحاله يعتقل الاشخاص
المعنيون وتحل العمليه بهذه
الطريقه نعم هذا الشخص كان ايضا ملاحقا من
قبل اجهزه الامن الفلسطينيه و وبالتالي
اسرائيل لا يمكنها ان تضع يعني حياه مدنها
في كافه الخطر
وانا اعطيك يعني بدون شعارات كما سمعنا في
خلال عمليه السلام مع الفلسطينيين في
الثمانينات في عهد
راين الحماس والجهاد الاسلامي فجرت المدن
الاسرائيليه بال متفجرين المنتحرين
الفلسطينيين الاف
الضحايا 100 الا شخص لقوا حتفهم في خلال
ذلك الوقت في كل الباصات وفي المطاعم وفي
المتنزهات وفي كل مكان وبالتالي اسرائيل
لا يمكنها ان تعود الى نفس الوضع نحن
نتكلم عن تجربه وتجربه مريره عشنا بها
ولازال هؤلاء الضحايا يعني بيدفعو الثمن
غاليا الجانب الفلسطيني حتى الان يرفض
مواصله عمليه التسويه بيرفض كل المحاولات
من اجل الوصول الى تسويه وهذا يعود الى
عدم قيام القياده
الفلسطينيه عدم وجود لديها اراده سياسيه
للوجود للوصول الى ذلك طيب يعني الامور
متداخله هنا ولكن اريد ان اعود الى نقطه
التنسيق الامني هذه التي يعني اثيرت وتثار
دائما في ظل هذا التصعيد والاستهانه ربما
ب بجهود السلطه الفلسطينيه في هذا المجال
هل يعني من الواقع ان يستمر هذا التنسيق
الامني بين
الطرفين اعتقد ان التنسيق الامن ومجمل
الاتفاقات التي عقدتها منظمه تحرير مع
اسرائيل تجاوزتها اسرائيل بشكل كامل
اسرائيل لم تعد تلتزم باي التزام من
التزامات اوسلو وانما تريد من الجانب
الفلسطيني ان يبقى لوحده ملتزما بالتنسيق
الامني وب اعتراف باسرائيل وبنفذ العنف
والمقاومه واتفاقيه باريس الاقتصاديه اي
اتفاق اوسلو من جانب واحد وهذا وضع مستحيل
استمراره وعلى الق القياده الفلسطينيه ان
تراجع هذا الوضع وخاصه بعد ان اعترف
العالم بدوله فلسطينيه مراقبه مما يجب على
اسرائيل ان تنصاع للاراده الدوليه وتنسحب
من الاراضي المحتله عام 67 والتسويه التي
يتحدث عنها يعني الضيف عندك هي قدمت
القياده الفلسطينيه فيها مرونه مفرطه
وتنازلات غير
مسبوقه اعترفت القياده الفلسطينيه
باسرائيل على 78% من ارض فلسطين والت زت
بكل الالتزامات السياسيه والامنيه
والاقتصاديه ووافقت على حل متفق عليه
لقضيه اللاجئين ومبدا تبادل الاراضي
والكتل الاستيطانيه ودوله منزوعه السلاح
وتعهد الرئيس ابو مازن بانه لن يعود الى
صفد ولن يغلق اسرائيل بملايين اللاجئين
وبعد ذلك يقول يقول ان السلطه لم تلتزم
بالتسويه
اك سيد هاني واعود اليك سيد مائير هنا
يعني كما ذكر هاني المصري اسرائيل تبدو
انها تكسب على كل الجهات منها مسار
المفاوضات كما ذكر الجانب الفلسطيني هو
الذي يقدم تنازلات اسرائيل تتمسك بموقفها
على الصعيد الضغط الامريكي والدعم
الامريكي ها هو ابو مازن عاد بخفي حنين من
واشنطن كل ال التهدئه من الجانب الامريكي
على اساس انه الخوف مما يمكن ان يحدث في
الجانب الايراني من وجهه نظر اسرائيل
ايضا المستوطنات
ملف يعني الميداني كل هذه الامور اسرائيل
تبدو هي الكاسب ونعود للسؤال اذا لماذا
تلجا الى التصعيد بهذه الطريقه ما الذي
تكسب من وراء
ذلك نحن نعود مره اخرى الى موضوع التصعيد
انا اذا سمحت لي
بالنسبه للتنسيق الامني اولا بدون التواجد
الامني
الاسرائيلي في اجزاء من الضف الغربيه
السلطه الفلسطينيه لما بقيت على الوجود
حركه فتح
ستنتهي هذا ما حدث في قطاع غزه في خلال ست
ساعات انتهت حركه فتح وانتهى ابو مازن
هناك وكل شيء كل ما يتعلق بالسلطه
الفلسطينيه انهار في خلال ست ساعات و600
و600 فلسطيني من من حركه فتح تم قتلهم هذا
هذا الواقع لماذا نهر من الواقع هذا اولا
بالنسبه لعمليه التسويه هناك ورقه امريكيه
تتحدث بوضوح اعدها وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه معروفه باتفاق
الاطار يبدو وواضح ان اسرائيل تتجه الى
قبول ذلك اولا من نقطتين انها تريد تحقيق
التسويه ثانيا هي لا تريد ان تعيش دوله
ثنائيه القوميه وبالتالي هي ترغب في
التسويه من الذي يعيق عمليه ق قبول الورقه
الامريكيه نتنياهو يتجه الى قبول الورقه
التي في صلبها في صلب هذه
الور الشارع الفلسطيني سيد مائ الشارع
الفلسطيني الان يتحدث عن مطالبه بايقاف
اصلا المفاوضات في ارضها بسبب هذا التصعيد
الاخير سالت لماذا نعود لقضيه التصعيد لان
التصعيد الان هو في صلب اطار ليس فقط هذه
الحلقه في صلب الموضوع الفلسطيني والبعض
يتحدث عن رفع نبره الرد الفلسطيني الى حد
المقاومه وخيار المقاومه من جديد هذا ما
سنطرح بعد الفاصل ارجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد الى حلقتنا نناقش
فيها خيارات الطرفين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي بعد التصعيد في ضوء على ضوء
التشرذم الفلسطيني وايضا على ضوء الموقف
الاسرائيلي هاني المص ري هل تتوقع فعلا ان
يتمسك ابو مازن
ب خيار المفاوضات بعد كل ما يجري
الان اولا اتحدث عن ما ينبغي وبعد ذلك يا
انتقل الى الحديث عما اتوقع ما ينبغي ان
يوقف ابو مازن مهزله المفاوضات وما يسمى
عمليه السلام وما هي عمليه السلام لانها
تؤدي الى تاكل الارض والحقوق والقضيه
الفلسطينيه وتمكن اسرائيل من الايحاء
للعالم انها معنيه بالسلام في حين انها
تستغل المفاوضات لتعميق الاحتلال وتوسيع
الاستيطان وتقطيع الاوصال وقطع الطريق على
اي امكانيه لحل وجعل الحل الاسرائيلي هو
الحل الوحيد المطروح والممكن عمليا
اسرائيل لا تبحث عن تسويه واتفاق الاطار
الذي يتحدث عنه يعني مئير كوهين هو يمثل
وجهه النظر الاسرائيليه من حيث الجوهر
والا ما معنى ان تبقى القوات الاسرائيليه
مثلا على الحدود بعد قيام الدوله
الفلسطينيه اي دوله هذه هذه ليست دوله هذه
محميه اسرائيليه هذه حكم ذاتي يسمى دوله
اما عن مساله ما يمكن ان يقوم به الرئيس
ابو مازن ابو مازن اثناء لقائه في اوباما
طلب حتى يمدد المفاوضات بان يتم اطلاق
سراح دفعات جديده من الاسرى وان يتم تجميد
الاستيطان واذا تمسك بهذين المطلبين خاصه
اذا شملت الدفعات التي يطالب بها شخصيات
من الاسرى من وزن مروان البرغوتي واحمد
سعادات وفؤاد الشوبكي او تجميد حقيقي
للاستيطان هذا لن توافق عليه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه لانها حكومه متطرفين
ومستوطنين وترفض اي تعاطي على الاطلاق مع
الحد الادنى من الحقوق الفلسطينيه وحتى مع
القانون الدولي وقرارات الامم المتحده
لماذا نبحث عن عن اتفاق اطار لماذا لا يتم
تطبيق قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه قرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه التي اصلا قامت اسرائيل
بناء على احد قرار هل تعتقد ما يجري سيد
هاني هل تعتقد ما يجري كافي يعني كنا
نتحدث في في مواقف كثيره الاستيطان وغيرها
هل ما يجري الان كافي لكي يقنع الرئيس
الفلسطيني ربما باتخاذ موقف حاد من هذه
المفاوضات وايقافها بشكل سريع لو سمحت انا
اقول يجب ان يكون كافيا وعليه ان اذا اذا
افترضنا سيد مائير كون اذا افترضنا نعم
اذا افترضنا انه كان كافيا وافترضنا ان
يعني ح حاله من الاستفزاز حصلت الشارع
الفلسطيني استفز بما يكفي حصل نوع من
التغيير والضغط على القياده الفلسطينيه
باتجاه ايقاف هذه المفاض ماذا بعد ماذا
ستفعل اسرائيل
هنا تبقى مسؤوليه الجانب الفلسطيني وهذا
امر سهل بالنسبه لاسرائيل
لكي يبدو للعالم ما هو يعني الموقف
الفلسطيني الذي يرفض كل عرض واصبح
الفلسطينييون يعني هم يرفضون كل كل تسويه
ولا يفوتون فرصه الا ويفوت فيها كل الفرص
وهذا يحدث من عام 48 الى اليوم ولكن
العالم الان ينظر بطريقه مخت يعني في الس
قبل قبل سنوات كان كان هناك تعاطف اكبر مع
الموقف الاسرائيلي اليوم يعني هذا الموقف
لم يعد كذلك انت تقول العالم كله سيقول
نعم اسرائيل معها حق هي التي تق دائما
دائما الطرف الاخر اليوم اليوم الامور
تغيرت النا يعني ان العالم ينظر الى ما
يجري على الارض ويحمل اسرائيل سواء في ملف
الاستيطان سواء في ملف الاغتيالات يحمل
اسرائيل مسؤوليه
اكبر مضبوط ولكن الذي يبدو وموقف الاداره
الامريكيه والاتحاد الاوروبي الان يعتبرون
ان الجانب الفلسطيني هو الرافض لهذه
الورقه ما الذي يمكن ان نفعله هذا هو
الواضح ف فهناك فرص وكانت هناك فرص اكبر
ورفضها
الفلسطينيون وبالتالي لا يمكن يعني رمي كل
المسؤوليه على الجانب الاخر انا بقول يعني
اسرائيل طبعا ملامه لانها لم تتقدم اكثر
ودفع عمليه التسويه ونريد العيش بسلام وكل
ذلك ل لكن الذي يبدو من الجانب الفلسطيني
ان ابو مازن لا يريد التفاوض من اجل
الوصول الى التسويه وانما يريد انتم تح
ربما الجانب الاسرائيلي يحرج ابو مازن
اكثر يعني عندما يضرب بهذه الطريقه هذه
يعني هذا الملف مثلا ناخذ هذه الحادثه انت
تقول ان ليست يعني لماذا نعود اليها ولكن
هذه الحادثه مثال جيد على على الاستفزاز
والاحراج الذي ينال طرف مثلا مثل ابو مازن
الذي من مصلحته وكما عبر في في اكثر من
لقاء صحفي ان يمضي قدوما كل ما يقترب من
تحقيق اي شيء تقومون انتم بشيء الان مثلا
سمعت فوزي برهوم يقول اننا يجب ان نعطي
صوت للمقاومه لا خيار الا المقاومه على
الضفه ان تتخلى عن التنسيق الامني ان تعود
كل هذا يعني اسرائيل نجحت في ان تفعله لا
ادري عن عمد ام ماذا يعني هنا هذا هو
السؤال الذي ربما يستحق ان نتوقف
عنده
نعم السؤال مضبوط وواضح ومفهوم ولكن ما
الذي تتوقعينه من
اسرائيل في حال تعريض مواطنيها للخطر
وذكرت لحضرتك امثله عديده من عمليه
التسويه عندما فجرت حماس المدن
الاسرائيليه بالمنتحر
لم يكن في وسع شخص ان هو يتوجه الى مكان
وهو في حاله خوف وهلع لا يمكن الدخول في
مطعم لا يمكن الدخول في مركز تجاري ركوب
في الباص اصبح مساله كان الواحد سيذهب بعد
لحظه في يصعد الى السماء وامور كانت ويعني
افتحي حضرتك كل الملفات في هذه هذه الفتره
وانت تجدين يطالب الان بنقل تجربه
الصواريخ الى الضفه هل هاني المصري هل ترى
ذلك واقعيا هل تعتقد ان هذا ممكن ان
يحصل الواقعي هو ان يق
الشعب الفلسطيني وقيادته وقواه المختلفه
عن اجذوبه ما يسمى عمليه السلام ويفتح
طريق لخيارات واستراتيجيات جديده تعتمد
على تعزيز الصمود ومقومات الوجود
الفلسطيني على ارض فلسطين وتنظيم مقاومه
شامله مثمره والاستعانه بكل القوى
والعناصر في العالم المؤيده للحق
الفلسطيني على خلاف ما قال مائير لان معظم
دول العالم وبما في ذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي
ينتقدوا وضد السياسه الاسرائيليه صحيح
انهم لا يقوموا بكل ما عليهم لتحميل
اسرائيل المسؤوليه ولكن الدليل على ما
اقول ان
138 دوله اعترف بدوله فلسطينيه على حدود
67 وفقط تسع دول بما فيهم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي التي عارضت وبالتالي
اسرائيل هي في الموقع المدان لان اسرائيل
دوله محتله ومن يقوم بالاح انا سالتك سؤال
محدد عن تجربه الصواريخ وانت انت اجبتني
بكلام عن السمود والموقف الموحد وما الى
ذلك وايه
الكلام السي هان
الم الصواريخ ليست هي الاسلوب ليست هي
الاسلوب المناسب في ظل الاختلال الفادح في
ميزان القوى هناك مئات الاساليب
المقاومه يجب ان
نعم هنا عشرات اساليب المقاومه نستطيع ان
نستخدمها والتاريخ الفلسطيني والنضال
الفلسطيني غني جدا بهذه الاشكال في مقاومه
مسلحه تستهدف قوات الاحتلال في مقاومه
شعبيه في مقاطعه في ملاحقه اسرائيل
دوليا انا لا اريدك ابدا ان تتكلم
هذا من حقك تقول ما تريد ولكن انا اريد ان
احصل على اجابه واضحه في هذا الخصوص انت
قلت ان يعني يجب ان يكون هناك موقف
فلسطيني موحد بهذا الخصوص وان تجربه
الصواريخ لا تنفع ولكن يعني في ضوء
الانقسام الحاصل حاليا يعني يبدو
هذا يؤثر على اي فرص يعني رد فعلي من
الجانب الفلسطيني الى اي حد هذا الكلام
واقع حتى
الان
نعم صحيح ان حاله الانقسام المدمر تستنزف
طاقات الشعب الفلسطيني ومفروض من الشعب
الفلسطيني ان يتحرك لفرض ارادته على
الفرقاء المتخاصمين في الساحه الفلسطينيه
حتى تقوم وحده وطنيه على اساس وطني وعلى
اساس شراكه حقيقيه وعلى اساس برنامج وطني
قادر على جعل الاحتلال مكلف لانه اذا لم
يصبح الاحتلال مكلفا لاسرائيل ومن يدعم
اسرائيل لا يمكن ان تنسحب اسرائيل يمكن ان
يتحقق حتى الحد الادنى من الحقوق
الفلسطينيه شكرا جزيلا لك هاني
المصري كنت معنا مدير مركز مسارات الابحاث
السياسيه ومن القدس معنا مائير كوهين
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي شكرا لكما وشكرا
لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج م وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن
الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد
فيما
[موسيقى]
ا